welcome to this episode of the
intelligence squared podcast with me
helen chersky i am delighted to
introduce our guest today joe
marchant she's an award-winning science
journalist and the author of many books
including decoding the heavens and the
shadow and the cure it's an
astonishingly wide range
and her latest book is the human cosmos
the secret history of the stars which
has just been published
and so we're going to be talking about
the themes of that book
and some of the examples in there and
i'm genuinely looking forward to this
because there is
so much in here to discuss i've got a
copy of the book right here it's got a
very beautiful cover
it always judge a book by its cover
right it's always a good start
but what's inside really lives up to it
and a quick reminder before we get going
that
if you enjoyed today's podcast uh don't
forget there's a little like button you
can like us
and subscribe to the intelligent square
channel
and if you have strong views on our
discussion or even
medium views do feel free to share those
with us in the comment section below
so first of all joe genuinely
congratulations on this book it is
brilliant
and um it's so vast in scope there's so
much detail in there and also so much
clear thinking
and i have to start by showing uh
congratulating you i'm showing the
people on the video the podcast won't be
able to hear this but
um the contents page is a star chart how
cool is that
was that your idea it was and i never
thought they would let me get away with
it
but they actually did it and i'm so
happy because i think it looks great and
it i like that the fact that it kind of
comes around full circle
kind of fits a little bit the arc of the
book so yeah
yeah fabulous and so this this is a book
that goes
right uh to the heart of a question
that's becoming more and more important
for western science i think which is
how do we connect science and meaning in
life
and sometimes it seems like science
takes us away from meaning and it's all
about numbers and data and measuring
things
but i think you you show us that they
they do come together
so let's start at the beginning you know
this idea of studying the cosmos and
studying the humans being seen
as two separate things what made you
think that it would be nice to bring
those together
it was a few different threads coming
together so
i suppose one of them is from my book
decoding the heavens that you mentioned
so i wrote about the antikythera
mechanism in that this ancient greek
clockwork device that it was 2000 years
old made
in ancient greece and it essentially
modeled the cosmos and that got me
really fascinated by
this idea that people all through
history have looked up at the stars
and wondered at it and the sort of
different stories they told about it the
different
ways people had of understanding it and
you know that sort of thread coming to
now and the idea that actually we're
losing that
view of the stars so with light
pollution we're kind of the first people
ever not really to be able to
see that sort of full glory of the
heavens if you like you know 80
of us can't see the milky way anymore 80
of people in
europe and the us that is so part of it
was
wanting to explore what that view has
meant to people through history and
you know does it matter now that we're
losing it and then that other thread
came from my last book
cure which was it might sound unrelated
initially but it was looking at the role
of the mind in physical health so it got
me very interested in the relationship
between
mind and body and also how science can
get at bats that some you know science
is a little about what questions you're
asking
and and sometimes in medicine in western
medicine we've ended up
treating people as physical bodies
rather than taking into account
sort of the whole person um and so that
got me interested in well how can we get
at
experience and meaning and belief and
hope and all of these things and how
they
impact on our health so it was bringing
that approach as well
to the cosmos how do we make sense of
reality and we've got this you know
we've built this wonderful scientific
understanding of the universe which is
you know
beautiful and elegant and we can see you
know further than
our our senses ever could with you know
the telescopes that we have and all
these amazing things that are going on
in the cosmos
but i also wondered if maybe we've lost
something in terms of that
the meaning and the stories and the
importance of our experience
i suppose of the stars well it's very
striking isn't it so i don't know about
you you know so i studied um
physics and you know we learn about the
stars and you you do lessons and you
learn even in school you learn what the
milky way is
and i remember being out in a desert
somewhere when i was perhaps 20 years
old
and going outside at night and going oh
that's what they were talking about and
i have been writing about it i've been
answering questions on it all my life no
one ever showed me did you have a
similar
do you remember discovering the cosmos
for yourself like that
yeah i mean i've had a few times in my
life where i've been places where you
get that chance but there was just one
particular episode that i mentioned in
the book when i was in the
mountains of mexico on a completely
different assignment
and it was a very sort of very stressful
and
slightly dangerous journey should we say
to get there and then this huge
rainstorm when we arrived there was a
power car was in this tiny little
one-person
tent thinking i was gonna get washed
away and then woke up in the middle of
the night when the rain had stopped and
came
outside and looked up and it was just
that wow
feeling that total ore because
we forget you know you go to the
countryside maybe and you look up and
you see the stars that we can't see in
london and you're like oh look kids
there's the stars but it's
not the same as when you just see that a
full
kind of dome above you i just couldn't
believe
you know there wasn't any dark it was
just all silver it was just all of those
stars and
that feeling we get when we look at the
stars that we it's
so rare now and part of what i'm also
looking at in the book is what does that
do to us
you know how does that view change us
you talk about in a way
the book is about it it acknowledges
that perhaps the great achievement of
science in some way has been taking us
out of the universe but actually by the
end
um you sort of i've found myself
questioning whether that was an
achievement or not
whether we need to retrace our steps a
bit how how do you see that balance
between like
this idea we'll come on some of these
ideas but taking ourselves out of it was
that was that the right thing to do
yeah no you're absolutely right that and
i wasn't i didn't plan this when i
started writing the book but what came
out of it as i sort of was tracing that
story from the paleolithic times and the
cave paintings through the sort of birth
of science and the understanding we have
now like at every step of the way
you could see our own experience
being taken out and we're sort of
abstracting our understanding of time
and and space and you know we've built
this sort of
yeah physical understanding of the is
made up of like
particles and forces that follow
mathematical rules and that is an
incredible achievement we understand so
much because we've done that we have
this objective framework that we can
agree on
and build on and that's a really
wonderful thing
but we've kind of forgotten about the
other half of the picture
it seems to me at least i don't think
all scientists would agree
with that but i was left feeling that
the meaning we find in the stars the way
we feel when we experience the stars and
the way that it
push it makes us feel connected and
pushes us to a sort of more
bigger picture understanding of this
cosmos that we're part of we're so sort
of focused down in our modern lives now
onto
onto screens and adds a little daily
existence that i think that
is a perspective that is also important
that um
previous societies have kind of prized
that kind of
that view of things and it's
it's something that yeah something that
i think we've forgotten so i think it's
it is a wonderful achievement but i
think we also need to pay attention to
the
things that we've sort of thrown out
along the way well let's let's go back
to the beginning
and and start with what we've thrown out
uh so the book starts
with some of the most famous cave
paintings in the world in moscow
and so could you sort of set the scene
for us before you know the modern world
mucked all this
up the people who made those cave
paintings what do we know about
the way they saw the sky and what was
their relationship with it so
i should say first of all it's really
difficult to say anything for sure about
what people of the paleolithic 20 000
years ago were
thinking and believing when they made
cave paintings
but what we can do is look at lots of
different lines of evidence and see kind
of where they're converging what kind of
picture is that building
so i was really interested as a starting
point in yeah lasko cave which has got
these you know incredible paintings of
animals
of oryx bulls stags horses covering its
walls and there's one in particular
the biggest oryx bull in the cave called
bull number 18 and it
has these six dots in a sort of curious
pattern a line of four in a line of two
just above its shoulder
and that same pattern of dots appears in
lots of other arts sort of around the
the planet and through history um
from sort of native um american people
to
siberia to um a very similar pattern is
in the logo of the japanese car
manufacturer subaru
and they all represent the star cluster
the pleiades
and the the one in lascaux is so similar
and what kind of
really makes it interesting is that it's
above the shoulder of this bull and the
pleiades star cluster is in our modern
constellation taurus just at the bull's
shoulder
and in the cave painting it's also got a
very prominent eye you know you can put
the ball next to a drawing of
of of taurus and you've got the sort of
the horns that are defined by stars
you've got the prominent
eye which is the star aldebaran you've
got the sort of speckles on the face for
the heidi so
it's led to this idea you know is this a
star map were the people of the
paleolithic
you know basically painting the stars
when they were painting
these animals and there's some really
interesting
research looking at um analysis of myths
um where you can take a myth
whether there's different versions of
the story appear all around the planet
one example
is the cosmic hunt where an animal is is
hunted and goes up into the sky and
turns into a constellation
and you find versions of that in ancient
greek myths in america in africa
and researchers have made these almost
like a phylogenetic
family tree of these different myths of
what components are sort of
um present or missing in the different
myths and concluded that
that story actually goes back to
northern eurasia in paleolithic times
so that's a piece of evidence telling us
that actually it's plausible that
stories about the stars
could have survived that long so just to
be clear here that the brilliant idea
behind this is that
just you know mistakes or changes creep
into stories
and so just like you can with genetics
you can kind of say oh this one's very
similar to that one and then it branched
off a bit and became a slightly
different story and you can actually
draw
trees of this naturally so they evolved
over time and
different peoples i mean sometimes it
might be just mistakes to
misrememberings
it's also that different people were you
know that the star would change
depending on which constellation was
important
to the those people in that you know
that was visible in that part of the
world or the animal would change whether
it's a
a bear or an elk um depending on
which animals were important so it's
yeah so they're changing over time and
so
they divided the myths up into little
sort of components you know what was the
animal was it one hunter or many
you know and basically
encoded that into a sequence of ones and
zeros depending on the presence or
absence of these different myth
components essentially and then run the
phylogenetic software just as you would
for dna to come up with the family tree
so it's a really fascinating approach um
so that's kind of some additional
circumstantial evidence
that you like that there were stories
being told about the stars that
and they can sort of survive in some in
some form
until now um there's also work looking
at hunter-gatherer communities sort of
recent and traditional communities now
how do they live what the stars mean to
them and the pleiades are actually
important to
traditional communities all around the
planet the rising and setting of the
pleiades
is used in a lot of traditional
calendars and it's often tied in with
events in the natural world that are
important to people in native america
it's very much linked to the life cycle
of the bison for example so when the
pleiades set it's time to hunt
so we're seeing that link between the
bison and
the cycle of the pleiades um and so
there there's an idea that
actually the pleiades would have defined
the mating season of the oryx
bull so it could have been that there's
a link made between
you know what's happening in the sky and
what's happening with the oryx
um on the ground um and so
by i won't go through all of the all of
the different lines of evidence now but
you can put that together to and i think
for me i i feel that it is actually
quite plausible that this
could be a representation of the
pleiades in the sky and what it does all
add up to is
a very holistic view of the cosmos so
events in the sky and events on earth
were seen as completely
entwined you know one was was causing
the other um there wasn't any particular
distinction
yeah either between earth and sky
between people and nature it was
between you know objective and
subjective reality it was just
one kind of holistic experience if you
like so i think that's the best
guess we can come up with as to what
kind of universe those first people
lived in
so so the idea here is that they they
live in a world of stories basically
as we know tends to happen with
indigenous communities that's how they
keep track of what they're supposed to
do what their traditions are and how
they value ancestors
and the stories were written in the sky
as well as in the objects
on earth yes basically yeah so they're
so when they're the cave paintings for
example
they're they're painting animals but
they're not just painting animals
they're painting
the the sort of the creatures and the
stars if you like and it's all
entwined yeah well let's move on a
little bit in history now one of my one
of my
um well there's there's lots of things
one of the things that keeps coming up
in this book is
is this um it's perhaps an arrogant
um trap that western scientists have
kept falling into which is to assume
that people in the past
didn't observe very much they didn't
have measurement methods they didn't
sort of you know they just went around
hunting and and then again
these patterns come up where clearly
they could
observe and measure very well and one of
the examples of this but they used it
for a different purpose they didn't use
it to write science books
and just could you say a little bit
about the examples with the
um burial mounds because clearly there's
some very accurate observation going on
here
but they're using it to to deal with
what they do with the dead
yeah so this is moving on to the
neolithic now
so when we've got the birth of
agriculture
and people are starting to build with
stone
so this is passage tombs in ireland
stone circles like stonehenge
and you've got a lot of these monuments
are showing alignments with
the sun so there are small stone tombs
all across europe which are aligned to
sunrise
um probably on the day that they were
built but then you've also got these
much more sort of spectacular
examples so you've got new grange tomb
in ireland where it's
at the sunrise on winter solstice
there's a little sort of window
above the door and so a beam of light
just comes straight through and
strikes the floor right at the heart of
the tomb and then stonehenge is very
famous
um and you have the parties at the sort
of mid-summer but actually it was
probably
um sunset on the winter solstice that
was more important
and so it was at this time it seems that
that moment of
the winter solstice when this the sort
of the sun is receding
and then at the solstice it sort of
pauses and then the days kind of come
back to getting longer again so it's
kind of that journey into darkness and
then coming back into light towards the
summer that was a really
crucial moment and something that they
clearly were trying to
capture in these monuments um that these
sort of these beams of light
um framed in stone and went to huge
efforts to sort of
align these um these monuments
accurately it was clearly really
important to them and it seems to be
very much tied up with
the fate of souls after death and so
there's an idea that
you know that the the rays of light
would sort of shine into the tomb and
then perhaps would
be imagined to come back up through the
tomb and sort of carrying the souls of
the dead
back up into the sky um so yeah very
you know great attention to detail and
understanding of what was happening but
as you say a completely
different sort of idea of what the the
use and the meaning of that was
and it did have very practical uh
meaning so one of my i um i paddled
outrigger canoes and so i'm connected to
the polynesian
uh voyaging community and of course they
had this this great renaissance
in their knowledge of how that it was
possible for polynesians to navigate
across the enormous distances of the
pacific and not just to do it
by accident or once in a while but for
it to be a systematic thing
and and there's this lovely story in the
book uh where
you know and it is it's one of the great
meetings of mines i think in history
where captain cook meets topia who is
the
polynesian navigator so tell us a little
bit about the relationship between those
two yeah no i love this
story because it really is like two
world views colliding so
cook is his first mission to the pacific
and he goes to tahiti and his mission is
to
observe the transit of venus across the
sun and there are
teams being sent out by um different
nations all around the globe to observe
this this is a matter of great national
security because
by doing this you can work out through
the method of parallax how far it is to
venus and thus work out the size of the
solar system
which they needed for accurate celestial
navigation to work out
longitude and this was really important
for the european powers that were trying
to sort of
explore and colonize and dominate the
planet
and so that world view is all about
making accurate observations
uh developing better measuring
instruments translating that onto charts
like
you know complicated mathematical
calculations to work out
where they were um and then captain cook
meets
chupaya who was a priest and
a skilled celestial navigator and
ended up inviting him to come on and
sail on the
endeavor with him and unfortunately pyre
didn't survive
the trip back to england um but there
are
stories of how the crew were impressed
by how well he could navigate um he
could always point in the direction of
home apparently
he told the crew about and including
captain cook about lots of different
islands that were really distant and he
drew a chart
um showing where some of these islands
were that is still um in the british
library
um and that's been really interesting
through history the sort of attitudes to
that
because initially there was this sort of
excitement of well
what the polynesians could do and they
you know they didn't have any of these
instruments or charts it was all done
just through their their
senses and you know observing star
compasses memorizing star parts and
combining that with observations of
the weather of wildlife so very sort of
subjective holistic
approach um and then in the in the west
there was it
everything was very um sort of skeptical
there was this idea that this you know
these islands didn't really seem to kind
of match where they were supposed to be
and clearly the whole thing was just
you know didn't really mean very much um
but more recently there's been a
realization that you know tupaya
wasn't drawing a map in the same way
that we would think about it
you know we have i you know this sort of
mathematical idea of
of maps we measure longitude and
latitude and we mark the sort of
objective position of a location
on the map and then when we're following
the map we imagine ourselves as
as moving across that mathematical space
if you like
um and the realization was that for
tupaya he wouldn't have thought about it
that way what
in fact what he had drawn was a mosaic
of different
um bearings or sailing directions with
several different centers
so you had to mentally place yourself on
a particular island
and then his chart was showing the
sailing direction from that island
to get to the neighboring islands and
then you'd have to put yourself on the
next island to interpret the bearings
for the next set of islands
and when researchers kind of analyzed it
in that way they found that actually
it correlated with very distant islands
and that he had known about places that
were hundreds of miles away
um so it's just this nice
demonstration i think of how we can sort
of be quite
you know think that our sort of
scientific sort of mathematical approach
is is superior and and
sometimes not appreciate what other
approaches can achieve and actually
when you put yourself into pious shoes
and see the world and the way that he
was seeing it
you start to realize what you know that
they could also you know achieve these
incredible feats of navigation
and it sounds you know your description
and this is generally thought about to
power that he was
interested in the western world he was
like oh these people are doing
interesting things how do i that's why
he wanted to come along to sort of
find out um so yeah he's a really
interesting guy like he
yeah he made himself part of that group
if you like you know
here were these people that turned up on
this big ship and started building a
a camp and they had all these
instruments and he was just hanging
around because he
asking questions he wanted to know what
they were doing and
i'm not sure that cook and joseph banks
who was traveling with him were
were quite as interested in return i
wish they had been and then we would
know more about
you know two pies view of the world well
you touched there on something
very important which is that as you go
through the book there's this kind of
feeling that builds where you sort of
list
the ways in which humans take themselves
out of the universe that there's
there's maps and then we take ourselves
out of maps and as you described as a
grid and there's time and then
there's clocks and we kind of take
ourselves away from the clocks and
there's this progression of
and it sounds you know it's clearly no
one planned this but it's almost a
systematic
scrubbing out of humans from all these
different
aspects but um tell us just a little bit
about the clocks because that's
because obviously you know the sun rises
that's where we get days from but
there's some quite interesting things to
do with the clocks and and how we got
rid of ourselves
from the time yeah i'm a bit of a geek
when it comes to the invention of clocks
i think
from the antikythera mechanism i just
find just that invention of clockworks
is so fascinating but
yeah so you know initially you know time
was defined by
the cosmos by the movements of the sun
and the moon and the stars that we see
above us you know there wasn't anything
else you know the sun's moving and that
is the day and the night and the
the seasons um and
when when you start to have clocks so
and this was initially a big part of the
um
motivation for this was sort of medieval
monks who wanted to be able to time
their prayers more accurately so there
was a spiritual
motivation behind this and up until that
point
all ways of measuring time had been done
with continuous flow so whether that's
falling
sand or a water clock or a candle
burning and that kind of
is intuitive that makes sense right um
and it wasn't until
the invention of a little piece of the
mechanism called the
an escapement which sort of rocks
backwards and forwards so they were
experimenting with falling weights but
it's really hard to get that to do
at a constant speed but then when you
regulate that into chunks with this
little piece of mechanism that rocks
backwards and forwards
that keeps the speed constant but what
you've also done is you've
you've chopped up that flow into these
sort of regular sort of
seconds or or ticks of the clock so now
you've got like a digital rather than an
analog approach to time you know
you've made it mathematical you're sort
of counting those seconds
well it did start with the ticking of
the clock i mean that
that moment is that's really important
yeah well it actually started with the
ringing of a bell
because the theory is that this was the
mecha it's the same mechanism that they
used so initially they had the water
clock that would ring a bell to wake
them up
to then go and pray and it's that same
sort of hammer mechanism that was then
adapted
somebody thought oh we could use this to
sort of regulate the falling of the
chain so the ringing of the bell became
the ticking of the clock and that was
the moment that sort of time became
time was taken out of the universe if
you like and initially
the clocks weren't very accurate and
they had to be corrected to match the
position of the sun
in the sky but as clocks became more
accurate they became more accurate than
the sun because the sun's speed
varies as we see it in the sky um
and so then the clocks are more accurate
and it's the sundials that need
correcting to match the clocks and so
that was the kind of tipping point
the universe is wrong basically the
source that is no longer our experience
of the sky what we experience around
us it is held in these these machines
essentially and that's been an
incredibly powerful approach
you know we can now i couldn't even
say the fraction they are going to
remember it um you know the accuracy of
of of clocks now that are based on sort
of vibrations of the cesium atom it's
just
mind-blowing yeah and that's underlying
so many aspects of our lives and our
technology now in our communications
um so yeah it's just another example
yeah a little bit like the maps of where
we used to see time
as we did with space as a property of
the universe that we experienced and now
it's a sort of it's a mathematical
abstract
thing that we calculate which is very
very useful
but you've left something behind
one of my favorite chapters in the book
actually although that's a hard
hard battle to win was the point where
you started talking about
in spite of all this modernization of us
taking ourselves out of the universe
there were ideas from the cosmos that
came back down to earth and
and you framed this you discussed the
american revolution
and this idea that you need a balance of
forces and that that idea that sort of
vision like the scientific idea you know
newton and orbits and things were so
strong
that it actually started to invade
political discourse and tell us a little
bit about that
yeah i love this too because the
the way in which we see the universe
that you know the way we think the
cosmos works
has always defined how we live on earth
political structures
and elites on earth and you know you
look to ancient civilizations whether
it's the romans
the mayans the babylonians the chinese
it's
rulers are taking their authority from
the heavens they're modeling themselves
on sort of divine celestial beings and
it's
it's very hard to to question authority
if it's being drawn from
this is how the universe works but we
kind of think that well that's not
really where we are
now you know we have this much more
rational approach to things
um but but actually you can see how as
ideas about the universe changed that
fed through into political structures so
initially you've got
um copernicus putting the sun at the
center of the solar system
with the planets orbiting around and
immediately kings in europe started
modeling themselves on the sun and this
idea that they were the radiant
uh sun with their sort of subjects
orbiting around them
and then newton sort of revolutionized
physics with this idea that
you know you have these sort of physical
mathematical laws that define
the motion of everything in the universe
from a particle to
a planet so you know celestial bodies
aren't
these sort of divine beings that can
kind of do whatever they like they've
got to obey the same rules and so that
led to the idea well
if that's true for the universe
shouldn't the same laws also apply to
people from
commoners to kings and those ideas were
really influential during the
enlightenment and the revolutionaries
that were kind of
um behind the american revolution the
french revolution and you can see that
at the time with
the the imagery that people were using
in their language there was a lot of
astronomical um uh mechanical
imagery and and people were very
concerned about balance of power
and this idea between centrifugal and
centripetal forces that you
didn't want um sort of too much sort of
gravitational pull like
pulling everything into the central sun
but then you didn't want
if the ties were too loose you know
everything would hurt away into anarchy
and people were really interested in
you know how could you um design
governments to have that right balance
of forces
and this you know these newtonian
principles they they absolutely weren't
the only
you know there were lots of other
factors that were going on as well but
it is a very strong one that i think
often
isn't recognized and what i found the
most interesting was
in the american revolution so they had
very much been seen as a
you know a colony a planet orbiting sort
of english
king and government and then once they
formed their sort of new democracy of
the united states
they needed a new cosmic metaphor if you
like there couldn't be a planet
orbiting anymore so they came up with
this idea of a constellation of equal
stars
which i think is lovely and so there you
have the stars on the flag that's why
they represented the states
as stars so that you know those
newtonian ideals that idea about
this is how the universe works it's a
mechanical system that
you know is balanced and follows these
um
these laws these predictable sort of
explainable laws you know that's
at the heart of the democracies that we
live in now so we're we're just as much
a cosmic state if you like
it struck me that um there's a there's a
sort of hidden thing behind there which
is that that's some very good science
communication
i mean if you you know when a scientific
idea percolates
discourse in that way whether or not
it's accurate you know something like
the higgs boson coming along or cern
discovering something
um if it if it goes that far someone
really did well with talking about how
the universe worked and that's
interesting all by itself i think
yeah i think some ideas are just so
powerful and it must have to do with
the time being right as well but if you
look at you know ideas of evolution as
well you know there are just certain
scientific ideas that are so powerful
that they do
end up informing and you know
shaping so many other aspects of society
which you know is a really good thing in
one way you know people are being
inspired by these scientific ideas but
you know they're only
metaphors there are so many different
ways of seeing the world so
it also is sort of closing you off at
the same time to other ways
of seeing the world too but yeah and i
agree it's fascinating how much that one
has taken hold
well let's move on to so one of the
other turning points in your book that
i've never
thought about really is is the idea of
the difference between stars being
unknowable and suddenly being able to
know something about what they're made
of or what's inside of them
and this is obviously very topical at
the moment because someone's just
pointed some telescopes at venus and has
discovered some phosphine gas that
everyone's very excited about
but spectroscopy uh
which came along very early tell us a
little bit about the perspective shift
that that generated yeah so after the
um american and french revolutions there
was this really sort of
positivist view that you know science
and reason were going to be the way that
we were going to understand
everything um and um august kont
um was one of the sort of people really
driving this and he
wrote a lot about knowledge where
knowledge could come from um and he
thought it had to come from these
scientific methods and he wrote in great
detail what knowledge was sort of
possible or acceptable and what
knowledge wasn't and one of the things
he said we could never know
was the chemical composition of stars
because they were so distant
you know he said we can and we can look
at their motion and their behavior
but we'll never know what they're
actually made of and it was
literally a matter of a few years before
before chemists and businesses proved
him wrong and this was through
spectroscopy so the idea of splitting
the light that comes from
stars into a spectrum uh so that you can
look at the different
frequencies um so rather than just
seeing that um
you know one star might look a bit
reddish and one style might look a bit
bluish
you've got all the bands of light in the
spectrum and
the discovery um that
actually certain frequencies or
wavelengths of light are missing from
that
spectrum and these patterns correlating
with
different elements so you can decode the
messages hidden in the light if you like
to
to work out what different elements are
are present in stars or you know any
object that's emitting light to us and
that was the change that
you know we don't have to have a
physical bit of that stuff
on earth to work out what it is we can
use
the light and these stars it turned out
were made out
of exactly the same elements that
are on earth and that was the um
beginning of astrophysics really so
newton kind of showed that these you
know what previously been thought of as
these sort of divine celestial beings
were obeying physical laws of motion
and now we know that they're also sort
of obeying sort of chemistry and
they're made of the same things as on
earth so um
yeah that for me that was probably you
know just as much of a
revolution as as newton's ideas well you
can sort of hear in you know as you
think about these ideas through history
you can kind of hear the
the grumbling in the background of not
just the astrologers but people who
think these scientists are just taking
all the fun out of everything
that they're making they're measuring
everything they're going to make it
boring
that we can't have creative ideas
anymore
and and there's a chapter in your book
about
art which might be surprising to people
who are used to reading science books
but it's a great thing
and it starts with a play called victory
over the sun
which is either you know supreme
arrogance or supreme protest
so the artists were not entirely happy
about the scientists going around
measuring everything were they
yeah so there was kind of a backlash
against this positivist view that
you know knowledge is all out there
waiting to be discovered and we just
have to use our sort of our intellect
and our reason then we will discover it
and that will be the end you know we'll
know everything
um and this is the the beginning of the
20th century 1913
um victory over the sun it's described
as the world's first
hubo futurist opera which may or may not
require a title isn't it
um and one of the people behind it was
an artist called kasamir
malevich so this is in in russia and
he's famous for a painting called the
black square which was literally
just a black square but where he started
was with victory over the sun
and it really was um a sort of a cry
out against reason and it sort of seems
hard to think well what's wrong with
reason right you know it's
very reasonable um but
they really felt that it it was kind of
leading us first of all to a view that
there is only physical reality out there
um
and also that logic kind of forces your
thinking in very specific ways you know
you can only go down the sort of logical
mathematical route
and that you know human creativity is
capable of so much
more than that um so it was so the sun
was playing
the symbol of reason if you like so this
whole thing was they were trying to stop
logical thoughts so the whole thing made
absolutely no sense
so there was like clashing tones on this
um chords on this old piano
and there was these crazy costumes and
it was this weird
sort of dialect where the the words
didn't make any sense and there was like
just um i'm trying to remember that
there's an airplane crashed into the
stage and there's talking about um a
fish pond of
of turkish or thankful this is before
monty python by quite a long way
i can't remember all of the details now
but it basically was just this crazy
thing that just left everybody just
going
what was that which was the point um
because it was trying to stop
that logical thought and to see what
else was behind it if that makes sense
and so he spent his whole career really
investigating the nature of reality the
nature of cosmos
the cosmos but he rejected the idea that
it is purely
this mathematical framework that the
scientists have built up
um but that there was far more to it
than that and that our experience
is is key as well he talked about sort
of the cosmos inside the human skull
and how is that battle gone over time
because i mean
and we hear it now you know there's
famous feynman quotes about the beauty
of a flower and someone
you know an artist said to him oh you
scientist you're taking out the front of
it it seems that this has never gone
away has
has the battle sometimes gone more one
way than the other or or pretty much
has science been just taking over
gradually more as time goes on
i mean that's a really complicated
question um i think
there's definitely been the pendulum has
swung
in different directions and you also
have different perspectives
in different cultures as well and in the
book i've very much tried to follow the
sort of
western scientific world view because
that pretty much dominates
now so i was interested in how we got to
where we are
now but you know there are eastern
perspectives for example that would be
different
um i think after the
after the enlightenment and the french
revolution you had this very kind of
gung-ho positivist outlook and then
there was kind of a religious sort of
backlash and a romantic backlash
of you know expressionism and you know
our um
emotional response to things being
important
and then in the beginning of the 20th
century as well there was it was
actually scientific discoveries so
there were things like discovery of
radioactivity or
realizing that atoms were actually made
of even smaller
particles or um radio transmissions for
example the idea that you could send
invisible messages through the air so
there were lots of discoveries that came
at the beginning of the 20th century or
around the turn of the century that were
questioning this idea of a solid reality
out there and that's what a lot of
artists were responding to
and then you had this birth of quantum
physics as well and all the uncertainty
that that brought in about you know is
there an objective reality out there
so there was a moment up until the 1920s
where
people were questioning sort of the
nature of reality and
whether you can trust what we perceive
if you like
um and even you know the role that our
own consciousness might play in that but
since um once you get up to the sort of
second world war and after that i think
it's really swung back the other way and
we've gone back much more to uh
at least in the sort of obviously not
everyone agrees you know you've got lots
of different world views but at least
that sort of dominant scientific view is
ultimately our scientific approach of of
measuring and observing will explain
everything and there are
lots of people like daniel dennett sean
carroll brighton green
who would say that we might not
understand even consciousness yet
but ultimately it will be explainable
reducible to
in principle it could be understood yeah
through
you know we can use the maths and the
physics and the equations and we will be
able to break it down
and understand it and it's i think
just recently in the last few years that
there are is increasing sort of
questions
that people aren't 100 happy with that
and maybe with science we need to be a
bit more open-minded
about how we approach
that and that we might need new
approaches and new attitudes so that you
know pan-psychism is becoming more
popular this idea that actually
consciousness isn't either something
that doesn't actually exist so we don't
need to explain it which is one view or
that it just sort of
popped into existence when you know
humans evolved
but that actually it's a fundamental
part of physical matter
that it was everywhere after all not
sort of maybe thinking brains but some
form of rudimentary awareness
um there's also schools of thought in in
quantum
physics that actually sort of
time and the universe isn't quite what
we thought you know it that it's a bit
naive to think about a big bang that
happened and then billions of years
passing and then life evolving and then
we evolved and we become conscious but
that actually um john wheeler for
example physicist john wheeler describes
the universe as a participatory universe
rather than one big bang
billions of tiny flashes of creation
that sort of coming into the universe
coming into being as
we look um so there are all these
different perspectives
um that reality could be sort of
different to what we
thought of this just there's this
physical reality out there and we're
just
kind of observers of it and that our
experience isn't really part of that
reality and i think that's a really good
thing like i think we should be
questioning this and thinking
about where we fit you know we're not
just
you know in science we have this method
where you pretend that the observer
doesn't exist really you know you're
just
on some i don't know some floating thing
measuring physical reality and that's a
really useful approach for understanding
that reality but ultimately we've got to
work out how to put ourselves
back in oh well it seems the uh
it might be that the the science itself
is helping along that route so towards
the end of the book you talk about
um you know there may be ways in which
animals and maybe humans are influenced
by the rest of the cosmos in ways that
no one was expecting perhaps a few years
ago and this comes onto chronobiology
and the study of how how organisms keep
time ticking along inside themselves and
there's one obviously i'm an ocean
person
so i'm gonna i'm gonna pick the ocean
example um
but uh you know one of the biggest
migration on earth is that zooplankton
tiny little creatures come up to the
surface and go back down on the daily
cycle
and you describe evidence from the
arctic ocean where clearly it's dark for
six months at a time
and the zooplankton still rise and fall
but they don't do it on a daily cycle do
they tell us about that
yeah so they switch and they start to
follow the lunar day
so they rise and fall every not every 24
hours but every 24.8
hours with the moon and there's actually
a variation in the strength of it as
well with the phase of the moon
so you see the maximum at um full moon
and you know i just love that because
that's this you know this huge movement
this entire ecosystem and
when the sun goes down everything starts
to follow the moon and we're seeing
effects of the moon um
in aquatic species which perhaps isn't
so surprising because you know you've
got the influence of the tide
you've got animals with external
fertilization such as corals they're
using the phase of the moon to time
sort of their spawning to a very tight
window so you get these dramatic
mass spawnings and so they're using the
sun and the moon together
in a really clever way to give you these
very specific sort of moments in time
but even on land as well um from the
hatching of whipplewheel chicks to the
flowering of the peruvian apple cactus
the conception in serengeti wildebeest
in all different sort of niches of life
that the moon is
is turning out to be important and in
particular it seems to
be that um animals are using it when
different um either in different
individuals of the same species or
different species need to coordinate
activities in time and so that
those monthly phases of the moon are
actually giving a very useful time cue
um for species to be able to coordinate
um one of the things that that was most
interesting in all of that was because
we think of cycles of the moon and
werewolves and when the full moon comes
out then you know
it's the full moon but actually some of
the examples you talk about
they happen without the influence of
light which is a really
interesting idea perhaps contentious i
don't know how how advanced is the
science on that
so that is is really early days it's
kind of this sort of
oh this is really intriguing but people
are taking it seriously
um so yeah so a lot of the effects i i
mentioned are probably to do with
varying levels of moon light
or you know in the ocean you've got
water currents from the tides that are
then you know caused by the moon
um but there was a really interesting
study um
a couple of years ago in patients with
bipolar disorder
and so they have these sudden switches
in mood that are known to be triggered
by changing patterns of sleep
and so these patients trapped the timing
of their mood switches and their
sleep waking patterns over years and
what came out was that
those sleeping patterns were being
driven by lunar cycles
um so and the interesting thing is it
was nothing to do with
um the phase of the moon so light
couldn't have anything to do with it it
was the
um it was the tidal cycles the position
of the moon so that's hinting at either
gravitational effects or perhaps
effects on the earth's magnetic field
because the position of the sun and the
moon can also create these sort of daily
ripples in the magnetic field
and so the mechanism isn't known um but
there is
quite a lot of work showing that you
know there's a whole you know lots of
different species
are sensitive to very tiny changes in
the earth's magnetic field they use it
for navigation so
everything from butterflies to turtles
and hints some hints at least that
humans do have a magnetic sense
as well the fascinating thing about that
is that the implication of that research
is that it's actually coming from
insiders it's not an external cue i mean
it comes from something external but
if either of those mechanisms are borne
out
that's that's right inside who we are
built into us
we're connected yeah so it's an
interplay so with the effects of this
the sun on our clocks and the moon is an
interplay between these molecular
clocks in our cells that are encoded in
our dna
interacting with those external hues
from the sun
and the moon and so when you think about
it you know any clock
has to work in that way you need a
mechanism but then you need something to
set it so that it's running in time
with with your environment and so that a
lot of the research focus has been on
the sun because that's more
obvious and you know a lot of the
mechanisms have been worked out
but researchers are now starting to see
with a whole new generation of molecular
studies
looking particularly at aquatic species
that there are hundreds of genes also
that vary with lunar phases
so it's really the combination of the
sun and the moon
that's that's being tracked and and i
think i was just going to say that the
work on magnetism so there's always been
this
view almost of us of of animals as these
isolated machines
if you like sort of like we were talking
about a little bit separate from our
environment
but especially with the work on
magnetism it's sort of hinting at a
slightly different view of this kind of
electromagnetic cosmos that we're in
sort of constant
touch with and possibly able to sort of
perceive these very
subtle cues that we're not even
conscious enough so i think it's really
interesting how it
changes our perception of our
relationship with with the wider cosmos
well at the end of your book you use a
phrase that i had never heard before but
i think it's terrifying
and you talk about or deprivation the
idea that
you know the smartphones and computers
and they're kind of here we can see one
and it might be very interesting what's
on it but it's fundamentally it's this
big and it's here
and we're losing this idea of awe and
that
that's terrifying thing isn't it yes
i i know it's it's really yeah it's
gutting to think about that so this is
research
on on the emotion of all which is quite
new probably the last decade or so
and psychologists define or as the
emotion we feel when we're confronted
with something
vast so vast that it dwarfs us and that
we sort of struggle to comprehend it so
it's that kind of thing we talked about
at the beginning that
stops your thought and the vastness can
be sort of physically
large or it can be sort of conceptually
vast
but the idea is it kind of blocks that
rational thought and you're just left
with that
wow kind of feeling and this is
something that astronauts report when
they've you know been on spacewalks and
look down
on earth but also stargazing when we
look up at the stars that's something
that we
feel and one of the most common ways
that psychologists use to trigger all
in studies is to show people the stars
and it's showing that when we feel all
people become more curious and more
creative so and they're more
interested in what's going on around
them they pay better attention so
memories improved they're
happier and less stressed even weeks
later
but um what i think is really
interesting is it actually makes us
nicer people so after experiencing or
people
they make more ethical decisions they're
more likely to sacrifice
make sacrifices to help others they care
less about
money more about the planet they feel as
if they have more time
and also interestingly they sign their
names smaller
and estimate their own physical sizes
smaller and neuroscience studies have
shown that
activity in the default mode network in
the brain which is associated with our
sense of self
is reduced so it's led to this idea of
or inducing a small self
so it's shifting our perspective away
from our ourselves where we see you know
our own self and our own concerns is all
important and kind of everything
and forcing your perspective to
something much bigger and so people feel
more connected to other people to the
planets
to bigger things and i think that that's
really
important so the researchers have um
warned of this or deprivation in modern
society we're all sort of focused on our
screens
and said that they think this could be
something that's making us more
selfish more materialistic more
narcissistic and so
there's this idea of this kind of dial
of different um
states of awareness if you like where
you have sort of
logical rational thought at one end
which is very
efficient helps us to engage with
details and
the physical world but it's also quite
um
narrow it's it's limiting in some senses
you know you have to filter out a lot of
the noise to be able to focus down
and then or always giving us is that big
picture perspective so not the sort of
logical thought but just
seeing that seeing the whole picture
feeling our connection to something
and and i think if we're you know going
to solve a lot of the problems that
we're facing at the moment you know the
climate crisis for example we
clearly we need the science you know
we've got to understand what the
situation is we've got to come up with
solutions
i think we're also going to need that
that
awe that that connection that gives us
sort of the motivation to shift out of
our own sort of daily lives and realize
how we're affecting
the bigger picture um so the fact that
we're
losing the stars and also losing our
connection to nature
more generally you know you can get all
from all different kinds of nature
is really worrying and i think it is
partly
comes from the fact that we have
consistently downgraded personal
experience as an important source of
information and knowledge about the
world so
yeah so perhaps it's not surprising that
we don't value the stars you know
they're literally our view of the cosmos
we're part of is literally being wiped
away and nobody you know there's a few
dark sky campaigns but mostly people
aren't that worried and i mean i think
it's
huge we need that connection with the
stars
so just find that i mean if that isn't
an argument for uh re-examining the way
we run our society i don't know what it
is but
just finally if has writing this book
changed your relationship
with the cosmos and what recommendations
would you make if we if we all need more
ore in our lives what are your
recommendations for how we manage it
it has actually i wasn't expecting it to
but it has really made me question
that view of ourselves as the sort of
passively observing um this physical
reality
that's out there where you know what's
in your mind
your thoughts are kind of imaginary you
know they don't exist and but what
really exists is the sort of the
particles and forces out there and it's
made me my view of reality now
is much more that reality is in your
experience of every moment
and we can use the science and the
mathematical frameworks and the
equations to predict
you know with exquisite position
precision how the physical world
is going to behave but those are
it's a mathematical model it's not
reality so for me now and
everyone will have their own worldview
but for me reality is our experience
you know moment by moment and i think
that has changed
it's made me much more um
focused on the present moment which um
you know it's helpful in terms of you
know not not worrying about what awful
things that going on in the world
um and i i think if
personally i i would recommend you know
i mean it's everyone's personal choice
but for me
i i found that really useful and
fulfilling kind of way of looking at how
we
live and the reality that we're in and
the other thing i would say is look up
look at the stars but actually you don't
there's more than you can see even in
london then you might
realize you know you can follow the moon
venus sirius and
all of those you know that gives you a
connection with your celestial
environment i think lifts our awareness
and even if you're indoors and can't see
any stars just
imagining us on the planet in the cosmos
again kind of
lifts your awareness in a way like if
you're facing north it's not just a
compass direction
you're facing the the pole you know the
axis around which our planet is spinning
in space
and i think that on its own kind of just
shift something inside that you feel a
connection to something bigger that i
think is a really great thing to have
fabulous i'm i'm very sorry we're out of
time because i can carry on with this
for a long time
uh this is joe's book the human cosmos
you should all read it because it's
brilliant um
it's out now and that's that's it we've
reached the end of our time so
i'm helen cherisky you've been listening
to intelligence squared thank you for
joining us
thank you